hi everybody good evening that was so
fantastic you all I'm so happy you're
here
it feels like yesterday when we called
you but welcome to this Samuel Goldwyn
theater and into the Academy in the last
several years we've talked a lot about
being a truly international organization
an inclusive organization that
represents filmmakers from all over the
world
and I believe our new member classes
show that this is more than just talk
it's the substance of the Academy and
this program the Nicol program also
represents the substance of the Academy
because we are just as committed is
supporting identifying nurturing new
artists new filmmakers from around the
world as well of the thousands of
scripts that we received they came from
countries as varied as Barbados and Bob
way United Arab Emirates Nigeria New
Jersey literally everywhere I want to
introduce the this year's class the
winnowing out process is very elaborate
and we came up with the best of the best
I'll say their names and you can save
the applause for last so we can hear
everyone's name entitled you saw so you
saw them up there introduced but they
are vigil Qi May for black bring back
girl Sarah Jane in words for jellyfish
summer max Lance and Jen Bailey for the
queen of sleaze Kristen Rock maker for
last days of winter says or vitaly for
the great nothing I'm gonna say vigils
name one more time and vigil Jame for
bring back girl welcome congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
we're so proud such beautiful work now
embedded in these great Academy programs
this program are the hours and hours
that are volunteered by our governors
and our members so first I would like to
ask all the Academy governors who are
here tonight would you stand up please
thank you stay standing because I also
want to ask all the executive committee
members for the nickel fellowship
Executive Committee would you stand up
and all the Academy readers and this and
former committee members would you stand
up so all these people thank you for
your applause they gave so much of their
time and that's this hours and hours of
hundreds of hours of time that you've
given is what it takes to make a quality
program like the nickel fellowship so
thank you so much and thank you to our
fantastic staff Gregg Beal Joan why
Brian Grady they're coming together for
this and just a couple more thank-yous
for volunteers who made tonight's event
possible Academy members friends of mine
for over 20 years
I'm so proud to have you here producer
Effie Brown and yes and the incomparable
director Rodrigo Garcia yes I am so
proud of this event this particular
event it's the fifth year that we've
done it and to me this nickel I've read
it really represents all of our Academy
coming together to celebrate this great
art form so thank you all for being here
for this celebration it wouldn't be at
this level without the dedication and
the vision of our committee chair
she has also given hours and hours of
her time but has also spent the last few
years refining the program making it
more effective making it more inclusive
so that we truly honor the great voices
that we've selected here tonight